-Priyanka, have you ever
seen the show on YouTube
called "Hot Ones"?
-Yes, I have.
He almost killed my husband.
[ Laughter ]
-You eat spicy chicken wings
that get hotter and hotter
as you go, all while answering
questions about yourself.
-Okay.
-Do you wanna try it right now?
-Yeah, why do we do this?
-I don't know why.
-Why do we do this to ourselves?
-I'm already getting --
I'm already freaking out.
-I mean, I love spice,
but I'm just, like,
the escalation of it
is making me nervous.
-And he's the best guy to do it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for the host
of "Hot Ones,"
Sean Evans, right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The maestro.
-Okay.
-Jimmy, thank you so much
for having me back.
Priyanka, it is an honor.
And for those
who are unfamiliar,
"Hot Ones," it's really simple.
We have these wings.
We have an interview.
And we'll start here
in a Chill Zone and then quickly
work our way up to a hot sauce,
the Last Dab Triple-X --
more than 400 times hotter
than a jalapeño.
-What?
[ Audience groans ]
-Gosh.
-But --
-400, with two zeros.
-400.
400. But this first one
is a nice Chill Zone.
Los Calientes.
-Which one?
This one or that one?
-Start right there
at the handle there.
There we go.
-This is it here.
Los Calientes, okay?
That's this one.
-Nothing to fear.
4 out of 10 on our heat index.
-Mm-hmm, okay.
-It's okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-Good, too.
Okay.
-And, Jimmy,
I want to start with you,
because recently, we had
Ashton Kutcher on the show.
-Mm-hmm.
-And he told us this story
about having
to go to the hospital
because he was experimenting
with this Steve Jobs diet
where he only eats fruit.
-Mm-hmm.
-What can you tell people
about the "Cape Fear" diet,
where you just eat
turkey on toast,
and what are its consequences?
-I did this in college.
[ Laughter ]
Spitting because it's so hot.
I did it on college.
I just ate a turkey sandwich
for breakfast, lunch, and dinner
for like four or five days,
and it was a disaster.
I don't know why I did it.
I heard that De Niro did it
in "Cape Fear,"
and so I just did it
to try to get in shape,
and it was awful.
-Did it work?
-I didn't really
need to lose weight.
I was skinny, anyway,
but I just started
getting mad at people,
and I was getting angry.
-Yeah, I get really mad.
-Well, I wonder what
I have in store,
eating these wings of death
for the past four years.
But let's move on here to
Bravado Spice Co's Aka Miso.
We have ghost pepper,
and we also have Carolina Reaper
in this one,
all in one condiment.
-Carolina Reaper?
I don't even know --
These are names of peppers?
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
All right.
That's a little something,
right?
-Yeah, I feel a kick.
-Mm-hmm.
-But doable.
-It's doable?
-All right.
-Priyanka, we're gonna
shift the focus to you,
because in our
season 9 premiere,
we featured the Jonas Brothers.
-Uh-huh, uh-huh.
-And then, Nick said that
you gave him a pep talk
before his date
with the wings of death.
Do you remember
what you told him
about the perils
of eating spicy food?
And did he have any kind of
reaction afterwards?
-Well, I did tell him
that he needs to do this
for the Indians,
now that he's married to...
[ Laughter ]
...now that he's married
to my entire country,
that he needs to, like,
bring it home for us.
So he, like,
really tried to get it.
[ Laughter ]
But after your show,
it was a long conversation.
And a brutal three days --
-Why are you not eating --
Why are you not eating
your chicken wing?
-Oh.
Because I'm talking.
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
-All right.
Well, you know what?
I hope he did you proud.
He did us proud.
-He did me very proud.
-And here, we are moving on
to Da Bomb, a sauce Jimmy
knows all too well,
a sauce I know all too well.
I apologize in advance,
Priyanka.
-I don't like --
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughing ]
I don't like Da Bomb.
That what killed me
last time I did this.
Are you feeling something?
-Yeah, I feel it, I feel it.
-Well, get ready,
because Da Bomb is da worst.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
-Here we go.
-Just do it fast, all right?
-Okay.
-All right.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I feel it.
Mm-hmm.
-That is the worst.
-All right.
Anyone who watches
"Hot Ones" knows...
-Whoo!
-It sneaks up on you.
-...that we have
a recurring segment called
"Explain that Gram,"
and here, we have pulled
a great Jimmy Fallon throwback.
Let's put it up on the monitor.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy Fallon and Jay Z.
Priyanka, can you guess
what they were talking about?
And then, Jimmy, can you
set the record straight?
-I think Jay Z is trying
to buy the Fallon show.
The Jimmy Fallon show,
and he's discovering --
he's discussing how much
he's gonna get paid for it.
That's why he looks so happy.
-That's the weirdest photo
I've ever seen.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
I think I'm explaining to him
how weird my shirt is.
It's a very odd shirt.
Like, look at the pocket.
The stripes
are going the wrong way.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-Where was I?
What shirt was that?
Oh, my God.
-A timeless shirt.
-Aah!
-A timeless collar.
This is the Last Dab.
We call it the Last Dab,
because it's tradition
around here
to put a little extra
on the last wing.
-This hurts.
-You don't have to
if you don't want to.
-I'm shak--
My hands are shaking.
I really -- Look at this,
look at this.
My hands are shaking.
I can't stop shaking.
-You don't have to
if you don't want to.
-Why do we do this to ourselves?
-Oh, my gosh, Sean.
-Stay calm, stay calm.
-Oh, my gosh.
All right, I'm gonna do a dab.
I have to, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aah!
Oh, my God.
-All right.
Taking a lap, taking a lap.
Surviving the "Hot Ones"
experience.
-All right.
-I'm crying!
-Oh, I'm crying, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-All right.
Bottoms up.
-Sean Evans, you are insane.
All right, here we go.
-How do you do this every day?
♪♪
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Here we are
at the end of the line.
And, Jimmy, last time we played
a "Name That Impression" game,
and here we're gonna stay with
that theme, but it's on music.
I want you
to think about the first...
[ Laughter ]
...musical impression that comes
to mind with your mouth on fire,
tongue ablaze, throat singed,
sing the first one
that comes to mind.
Priyanka,
try to guess the singer.
-What are you saying?
What, what?
-Musical impression.
Musical impression.
-What about musical impressions?
What?
-The first one that comes
to mind, just sing something.
-Aah!
I have to sing a song?
-Yes.
-Uh, uh, um...
I can't think of a song.
♪♪
♪ Happy birthday to you,
happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
Oh, I have to do
an impression of somebody?
Oh.
♪ Well, you can tell
by the way I use my walk ♪
♪ I'm a woman's man,
no time to talk ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That would be The Bee Gees.
Let's make some noise!
[ Cheers and applause ]
For Jimmy Fallon,
Priyanka Chopra.
-That's Sean Evans!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How you doing?
-I can't talk.
-More "Tonight Show"
after the break, everybody.
Oh, my God.